[Music]
Picador all right then no that's my door
pick another door what's wrong with you
you know what you were right this is
your toe what's the matter you got a lot
of bad guys by mental
[Applause]
access granted access denied access
denied access denied through cobs and
Turkish or we've got unfinished business
sure sister took something from me a
virus could wipe out half the population
and I want it back
gonna tell me just what we're dealing
with here it's my sister family when
it's the fate of the world it becomes my
business his whole thing sounds really
dodgy look off your system listen oh and
the only way we survive this working
together like a team let's do this
buckle up that way you have no idea how
long I've been waiting to do that
the music's already started
I think we can hit it sick so you guys
are being hunted by an army of
mercenaries led by a genetically
enhanced soldier look at me
I'm Superman crazy
yeah he really is black Superman you
need to get off the grid
we're home
come on babies come home I'm sorry to
bring trouble here mama
but I need my brothers this family is
going to war we're gonna need cars and
guns
mama where's all our guns okay read up
on very noble mrs. Hobbs no answer is
trouble understatement
that's good old school all right
come on
Wow
somebody says not happening
[Music]